hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the Far Cry series has been with us
since 2004 and over the years it has
evolved into a must play series which
one do you thinks the best Far Cry 3
remained my personal favorite with Far
Cry 5 only touching distance away it's
time to go through everything you should
know before spending your hard-earned
cash let's quickly get this one out of
the way this is indeed a video game with
mature themes every single piece of
footage we have access to has the 18
rating in the bottom corner for a reason
in fact it's for a bunch of reasons the
violence and the GAR have been amped up
but it's also down to the premise of the
story which can make some people very
uncomfortable let me lay it out Far Cry
5 places you in Hope County Montana in
the USA this is the adopted home of a
good old doomsday cult known as Eden's
gate their leader Joseph seed who we'll
get to very soon has put plans in motion
to help the local populace embrace his
particular brand of Christianity or face
the consequences to some that's
controversial to others it's just
another story in a video game with that
out of the way let's start breaking
things down in previous Far Cry titles
we've had a set protagonist to propel
through the story Jason in Far Cry 3 AJ
and far cry 4 Oh I'm Sergeant Rex in
Blood Dragon sent for a medic to kill
him too dammit that was a good DLC well
in Far Cry 5 Ubisoft is giving us more
player agency which all begins with
character customization we now play as
ourselves crafting the character in our
own likeness or creating Xena Warrior
Princess what whatever floats your boat
it's now down to us what we look like
just like in other Ubisoft titles like
the division and Ghost Recon wildlands
dropping the fixed lead character opens
up a great deal of possibilities in Far
Cry 5 most noticeably and most
impressive the entire campaign can be
played with a friend from start to end
random matchmaking won't be possible
here but if you see our mate Dave
playing online jump in and give him a
hand
tactically this will give the game
additional depth and replayability
hopefully if you choose to play this way
you and your BFF will fill the shoes of
newly appointed deputy sheriff sent to
arrest Eden gates leader father Joseph
and you can guess how well or how badly
that will go the body system from Far
Cry 4 returns in Far Cry 5 in the shape
of the guns for higher mechanic in the
level we played we had access to boomer
a loyal dog who can mark and take down
enemies and even unarmed foes and bring
the weapons back to you
there's also Nick Rai a family man who
has had enough of the cult and decides
to combine his love of aviation and
weaponry to take a stand against the
combining of the church and state and
we've also seen great who is a trained
sniper perfect for covert missions for
those moments where blowing everything
up isn't an option in addition to these
three companions there will be other
important character steering us through
the mayhem such as Mary May a local
saloon owner ready to mix a few Molotov
cocktails hold on a sec her
establishment is called the whistling
beaver I'm nice I didn't see that one
coming we'll also meet pastor Jerome
Jeffries a preacher whose patrons have
been led astray by the cult wall to the
man who leads my flock astray
if I am NOT THERE shown then I must be
the wolf
on top of this is a fangs for higher
function which was introduced during Far
Cry primal here we can command animals
to support whichever play style we want
the animals around hop County won't be
as varied as in Far Cry primal but they
will be useful nonetheless the one thing
that the Far Cry series is renowned for
is its leading villains somehow making a
madman seem logical
did I ever tell you the definition of
insanity and even making a tyrannical
dictator look like the good guides me
Far Cry fives head villain father Joseph
seed who is simultaneously deranged and
charismatic as he forces his religious
beliefs onto others Joseph's siblings
make up his apostles or lieutenants if
you prefer which will act as sub bosses
as you tear apart ol County looking for
clues and generally ruining Joseph's day
will father Joseph be on the same level
as vast or pagan min time will tell but
unlike the chosen one sent before God
will never let you take me far cry 5 is
a vast world to get around in and like
previous installments vehicles will be
pivotal from getting A to B like you'd
expect there's a plethora of road
vehicles to use and the fair amount of
boats - but it's the plains which have
evolved here
although Far Cry 4 had a small aircraft
to get around in it was pretty pathetic
here in Hope County airplanes have taken
center stage
prepare for dogfights with the chosen
and the obligatory carpet bombing of the
gods
look at that go sometimes disrupting a
doomsday cults and murdering hundreds of
foals takes its toll on us and we need
some rest and relaxation far cry we'll
have a few extracurricular activities
for us to enjoy recreate daredevil races
against time like Evel Knievel hunt down
the local wildlife and even go fishing
there's something about fishing in video
games that we just cannot ignore
we're so sophisticated whoever catches
the biggest fish will be forever known
as the Codfather it's suffering sorry
I'll scale down those fish puns far cry
5 has adapted the fighting system in
previous iterations to allow for more
close up and personal melee focused
action dozens of new animations have
been added to give you the option of
running in swinging if that suits your
play style so hopefully it will feel a
little less like Skyrim this time around
when scrapping in close range
a really interesting update to Far Cry 5
is the resistance meter this mechanic
takes note of all your dirty deeds and
reacts to them for example if you
disrupt jaws its cronies long enough one
of his lieutenants will actively seek
you out for an impromptu showdown
anywhere in the open world so
theoretically any of your actions could
trigger an event now that is a dynamic
world
the more you help liberate a region the
more the resistance meter will fill up
and the more resistance means more
people who fight by your side the
resistance meter plays very similarly to
how Ghost Recon wildlands plays with
different areas of the map being broken
into different provinces with a final
boss battle for each area of the map so
if you enjoy playing Ghost Recon
wildlands this could be another option
for you you remember the more you play
with their nerves the bigger their
reaction the map editor from Far Cry 4
also returns it 5 the developers
actively want you to use these tools to
create your own custom combat arenas or
new playgrounds to keep the game feeling
fresh and new we haven't had many
details about this at present but I'm
sure it will be showcased before the
release a strong community will keep a
video game going for years
let's hope people get on board and start
creating some missions for us to enjoy
speaking of the release date when can we
get our hands on Far Cry 5 well it has
dropped back by a whole month and now
it's March 27th 2018 if you're a
PlayStation gamer you might want to take
note of this far cry 5 has exclusive
items just for PlayStation users these
include a full baseball skin for your
character a car with a similar sort of
baseball theme and early access to the
SMG I know it's not earth-shattering but
it is a nice way for Sony to say thank
you for playing on PlayStation if you're
one of those people who likes to
preorder games you may want to have a
look at those bonuses paying for the
game early will net you the doomsday
prepper pack which gives you the
doomsday prepper outfit doomsday van and
doomsday 1911 handgun in addition you'll
obtain the chaos pack which is just a
load of consumables and buffs there's
also a deluxe a collector and the star
exclusive version of Far Cry 5 with
statues vinyl soundtracks and a dead
deer skull to hang on your wall that
sounds lovely
and finally Far Cry 5 has a season pass
to think about the season pass includes
three new adventures that transport you
to three very distinct locations
starting with Vietnam where you battle
the Vietcong in hours of darkness
that's followed by Living Dead zombies
which here I'm sure you've guessed
already pits you against the zombie
hordes like many other games and finally
lost on Mars the way you'll be leaving
earth to battle arachnids on the Martian
surface so messed up the season fast
we'll also net you the re-release of Far
Cry 3 later in the year
[Music]
okay I'll admit it I cannot wait for a
reason to go back and play Far Cry 3
again I miss vos and I a mrs. sister as
well if I'm honest so there we have it
12 things you should know about far cry
5 before it's released are you tempted
by another action-packed extravaganza
open-world I'm really looking forward to
hunting down Easter eggs and references
to previous games like the vast nodding
head in the truck Cup what I'd really
like to know is will you play this
campaign alone or will you play with a
friend I honestly can't decide which I
prefer
anyway I'm Adam from PlayStation granade
it's been an absolute pleasure as always
I'll see you next time
[Music]